près de trois mois après avoir commencé
un traitement contre son cancer des
poumons le chanteur florent pagny a
donné de ses nouvelles hier sur son
compte un star il a publié une vidéo où
il remercie ses fans où il revient sur
son combat bonne nouvelle il va bien et
c'est sa dernière séance de
chimiothérapie dernière regardez moi je
suis fan merci alors bonjour à tous je
viens vous donner un peu de mes
nouvelles le protocole a plutôt bien
marché puisque dès les deux premières
chimio immunothérapie ma tumeur qui
était grosse comme un kiwi s'est
transformé en une noisette ça s'est très
bien passé parce que j'ai été très bien
accompagné médicalement j'étais très
bien accompagné par ma moitié mes
enfants et puis il ya eu ce phénomène de
synchronicité avec ses milliers de
messages et de témoignages d'amour je
pense que ça aussi ça a contribué à me
permettre de passer cet cette histoire
de cette manière donc merci encore pour
tout ce que vous m'avez envoyé et puis
on se retrouve très vite
florent pagny oui une émotion mais
incroyable incommensurable quel courage
alors il fait ça parce que évidemment il
sera en direct dans un vol samedi donc
il voulait se montrer avant les directs
mais je trouve ça formidable d'abord que
ça et mieux son témoignage la dignité la
dignité ça concerne tous les malades ça
donne du courage aux malades je vois là
je je l'admiré énormément pour ce
témoignage bouleversant franchement j'ai
été hyper émules merci mais rien
palombes à nous allons vers le nord
il rien parce que vous avez hâte avez
des nouvelles alors oui oui
effectivement le traitement marche
plutôt bien la lada tumeur a été réduite
de façon très significative donc c'est
très encourageant effectivement il est
très affaibli par la radiothérapie la
chine où il a perdu plus de huit kilos
donc c'est assez voilà c'est un
traitement très difficile et très lourd
mais les médecins sont plutôt
satisfaits de la tournure que prennent
les choses et il a bien il a énormément
de chant de de mener correctement ce
combat contre le cancer du poumon va
très bien on lui souhaite vraiment l
établissement à florimont l'homme fort
c'est un artiste incroyable et un homme
incroyable